[Musique]
bonjour Sandra Seff bonjour monsieur
violton vous êtes secrétaire académique
de l'AI UNSA le syndicat majoritaire
chez les personnel de l'administration
et dans l'intendance au sein de
l'éducation nationale madame seort
quelle mouche vous appiquez vous vos
collègues de Guadeloupe et de guyan il y
a quelques jours vous avez édité un
courrier dans lequel vous dites que Fort
de France pointapitre Cayenne sont des
lieux de vilégiature des marqueurs
d'incompét le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale envoie chez nous des
personnels peu au fait de nos réalités
des personnels pas suffisamment
qualifiés pour mener à bien leur mission
alors pour être clair nous nous sommes
réunis à Paris he chaque trimestre tous
les responsables syndicau de toutes les
académies se réunissent sur Paris et
nous avons fait une réunion interdom et
Martinique Guadeloupe Guyane pour
discuter des problématiques inhérentes à
nos académies et le constat euh il est
lourd alors même que sur la Guadeloupe
et la Martinique nous avons directeur
compétent nous constatons qu'autour euh
de recteur il n'y a pas une équipe qui
tienne la route alors nous avons voulu
dénoncer euh à travers ce tracte
justement la problématique de la
gouvernance des académies c'est quelque
chose de très contextuel c'est quelque
chose que vous remarquez pour 2017 ou
bien c'est un phénomène que vous
observez depuis plusieurs années ça ça
dure depuis trop longtemps justement
nous voulons euh lancer un signal fort
au niveau du ministère et nos
représentants nationaux vont se fair euh
notre relais puisqu'ils vont demander un
rendez-vous au cabinet de la ministre
pour discuter de toutes ces
problématiques Sandra safort vous
décrivez pour la Guadeloupe un recteur
travaillant pour le guide du routard
Recteur Si sex and son ailleurs pour le
Cayen vous dites que c'est un véritable
défilé de haut fonctionnaire et ici vous
parlez pour la Martinique de
d'autoritarisme de secrétaire général
c'est c'est la réalité hein elle est
elle est elle est très difficile très
très difficile parce que au bout il ne
faut pas perdre de vue que ces
hautfonctionnaires doivent permettre à
aux élèves de nos académies de de
réussir leur scolarité et de devenir les
citoyens de demain et qu'est-ce que et
quells sont les conséquences immédiate
visiblebl pour les martiniquis les
Guadeloupéens les Guyanais alors il y a
des retards chroniques dans tous les
dossiers quand nous discutons avec les
responsables syndicaux des autres
académies une fois par trimestre on
constate que dans nos académies
respectives trop et trop souvent les
dossiers sont pris à la légère nous
sommes obligés nous sommes obligés en
l'état actuel des choses Martinique
Guadeloupe de faire appel à nos recteurs
pour pouvoir accélérer les choses
heureusement nous avons dans ces deux
académie directeurs qui sont réactifs et
qui agissent rapidement mais pourtant
dans votre courer vous mettez dans dans
le même lot recteur et secrétaire
généraux alors concernant la Guadeloupe
les collègues parlent de l'ancien
recteur qui a quitté l'Académie
justement ils ont lutté pour que ce
recteur là change et qu'ils a un recteur
plus expérimenté concernant la
Martinique notre secrétaire général de
l'UNSA Éducation a a été euh au
ministère chaque trimestre elle a un
rendez-vous et elle n'a eu de cesse de
répéter qu'il faut pour la Martinique
aussi un recteur expérimenté notre
demande a été entendue h malheureusement
ces recteurs ne peuvent arriver si
autour d'eux il n'y a pas une
gouvernance qui soit solide je rappelle
que dans les textes il est écrit
concernant la gouvernance d'une académie
qu'il y a un recteur et en cas de vacan
de poste c'est le secrétaire général qui
doit prendre le relais donc ces deux
personnes à la tête de l'Académie
doivent avoir un niveau d'expertise sans
faille les recteurs nommés chez nous
sont souvent des Primot arrivants dans
la fonction c'est ce que vous dites
également ah oui non mais je dirais même
que parfois ce sont des stagiaires he
ils n'ont jamais occupé la fonction de
recteur mais de là dire que la
Martinique la guadoupe la Guillan
deviennent des sortes d'école de la
deuxième chance pour ces personnels oui
oui euh pourquoi nos nos trois académies
c'est pas gentil pour eux hein c'est la
réalité du terrain pourquoi nos trois
académies ne mériteraient pas au même
titre que les académies de France
métropolitaine des euh secrétaires
généraux parce que dans le traac nous
parlons singulièrement des secrétaires
généraux pourquoi nous n'aurions pas
droit à des personnes expérimentées
depuis trop d'années nous avons des
stagiaires ces personnes n'ont jamais
exercé la fonction et elles font leur
année de stage dans nos académies on dit
euh ça suffit donc là nous demandons à
nos représentants nationaux de poser
cette problématique au ministère nous
estimons que nos élèves ont droit à
l'égalité des chances on parle d'égalité
des chances ils ont droit aux mêmes
chances que tous les autres élèves de
toutes les autres académies de fr asseé
que Martinique Guadeloupe et guyan soit
au queue de pelouton nous en avement
direct nous en avons assez alors il faut
savoir que là c'est la première étape la
première étape le trac c'est la première
étape fin mars le 30 et le 31 mars la
Martinique va accueillir les collègues
de Guadeloupe de Guyane et les
représentants nationaux et nous allons
débattre plus en profondeur de toutes
les difficultés qui sont présentes dans
nos académies et nous nous réserverons
le droit de décider des actions que nous
mettrons en œuvre pour faire en sorte
que il y ait du changement SAFOR qui est
le responsable de tout ça le ministère
on on va le dire clairement le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale est en charge
de la nomination des hauts
fonctionnaires on le dit très clairement
sans langue de bois quelque part c'est
pas votre faute aussi de laisser les
choses se passer comme ça depuis
plusieurs années tout à l'heure an vous
nous disiez que ça fait 10 ans au moins
que vous n' pas eu de personnel
suffisamment compétent dans les
académies alors il faut savoir que nous
les repr entant du personnel surtout à
l'UNSA nous sommes de dialogue on
établit un dialogue social donc tout al
ce ne va pas arranger le dialogue social
au niveau vous imaginez que ça fait
desà à un moment donné il faut mettre un
beauon coup de pied dans la fourmilière
nous discutons nous avons un dialogue
social mais il est il est pénible
toujours pénible de devoir lutter et
lutter pour obtenir l'application des
textes qui qui sont édictés par la
fonction publique alors que dans
d'autres académies il n'y a aucun souci
pourquoi faut-il que sur nos îles il y
ait toujours ce ralentissement au bout
du compte les textes sont appliqués ou
mais après avoir lutté là Guadeloupe et
Martinique nous avons la chance d'avoir
l' recteur nous alertons les recteur
mais est-il normal que nous dérangions
je vais le dire de la sorte hein le
recteur qui doit s'occuper de toute la
politique générale le secrétaire général
lui est responsable de l'administration
qu'est-ce qui vous a fait ce secrétaire
général en Martinique écoutez on va on
va être clair hein il est très cour trit
nous discutons très bien mais nous
estimons que quand on a une rectrice qui
fonctionne comme un TGV il faut que lui
il se mette en ordre de marche aussi il
faut peut-être expliquer à nos auditeurs
au nous parlons Sandra saintfort que la
partie administrative on en parle pas
beaucoup dans l'éducation nationale mais
s nous sommes les Oubliés pourquoi vous
êtes les Oubliés nous sommes nous sommes
les oubliés du système éducatif pourtant
pour expliquer à tout un chacun leur
fonctionnement hein les instances
académiques se réunissent et prennent
des décisions ces décisions les premiers
acteurs de la mise en œuvre ce sont les
personnels administratifs et ensuite ça
descend vers les autres personnels les
enseignants et autres alors c'est vrai
que nous sommes pas nombreux à peu près
460 dans l'académie mais ce sont les les
les petite fourmis qui œuvre au
quotidien pour faire en sorte que la
machine elle fonctionne correctement
vous avez euh distribuer ce
tracte depuis le 13 février dernier quel
sont les remous provoquer déjà alors les
les collègues ont été destinataires de
ce tracte alors nous sommes aussi
poussés par nos adhérents he puisque ce
sont les adhérents qui sur le terrain
nous disent on en a assez pourquoi à
chaque fois nos académies sont lésés h
donc en concertation les trois académies
ont décé don exemple donnez-nous un
exemple qui puisse parler aux auditeurs
lorsque vous dites que nos académies
sont lésées un exemple bien concret
alors on va on va on va en prendre
plusieurs exemples hein euh on peut
parler de la gestion euh prévisionnelle
euh des
compétences nous avions une ancienne DRH
qui n'avait pas la compétence le
secrétaire général et en charge de
l'administration vous constatez qu'il y
a des dossiers qui sont pas gérés ce
n'est pas faute d'avoir alerté et rien
n'est fait aujourd'hui nous avons des
départs massifs à la retraite et
derrière il faut que la relève puisse
suivre ce dossier-là il a trop traîner
il va il va s'enclencher avec la
nouvelle rectrice qui arrive et quelles
sont les conséquences pour
les parents qui amènent leurs enfants à
l'école aujourd'hui pour ses
élèves les pour les parents pour les
élèves il y a pas de conséquence on va
dire que il y aura un petit
ralentissement de la machine mais là
tout est mis en œuvre pour faire en
sorte que ce ralentissement ne se
produise pas mais heureusement
heureusement que nous avons une personne
à la tête de notre Académie qui est
consciente des problématiques quand on
les aborde alors dans votre sndicat la
UNSA vous avez fait ce constat sur
plusieurs années vous avez écrit
demander audience au niveau de najavallo
Belkassem vous avez certainement des
préconisations des propositions à faire
comment aimeriez-vous que ces personnes
soient nommées alors la la nomination on
ne peut pas avoir estce vous avez votre
mot à dire déjà on ne peut pas avoir
d'influence c'est ce que j'allais dire
sur la nomination ça rien al mais non
non pas du tout nous demandons au
ministère de prendre en compte la
spécificité de nos académies et que lors
des affectation qu'on ne nous envoie
plus de Primot arrivant nous voulons
dans nos académies directeurs et les
secrétaires généraux qui soi expériment
commencer un jour et ben ils peuvent
commencer en France métropolitaine il
faut il faut équilibrer les choses
pourquoi dans les départements du TR il
faut toujours des Primot arrivant trop
c'est trop le slogan de votre syndicat
administrer est un métier qui ne
s'improvise pas il ne s'improvise pas et
c'est le cas en ce moment là je crois
que nous avons beaucoup d'improvisation
dans certains domaine merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin Sandra saintfor
appppelle que vous êtes secrétaire
académique de la UNSA c'est le syndicat
majoritaire chez les personnels de
l'administration et dans les tendances
au sein de l'éducation nationale bonne
journée
[Musique]
merci